i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola hola
qué barbaridad díganme cosas bonitas
para que se me quiten los nervios
gracias
bueno bueno a ver cómo sale por qué
siempre pienso una cosa luego se me
viene otra y así va avanzando este mundo
les agradezco a los que me precedieron
en en el podium porque me ilustraron
muchas cosas muy muy interesantes
esto que están viendo ustedes es
procesos neuronales
llenos de caprichos los caprichos los
caprichos que nos rodean por todas
partes en los árboles en las montañas en
las hermosas grietas de la vida que son
reciprocidad a las grietas de la
naturaleza todo es capricho
el capricho el capricho ese que nos
mueve interiormente y que está esperando
pero la espera es una espera pasiva si
no es la esperanza real
el que espera algo es porque lo necesita
el que no lo necesita no tiene por qué
estar esperando pero siempre tenemos
necesidades y siempre tenemos que estar
en el mundo de lo que es la
la espera
la fe
esto que conecta el misterio
lo eterno con un instante que se
precipita que nos mueve y nos conmueve a
las creaciones sensibles
gracias
es a veces como los accidentes son
preciosos
los accidentes son los que realmente dan
razón de la vida
a aquellos que cuestionan las personas
que se viven planeando
cuando la vida es dúctil
cuando la vida es el arroyo
y que el arroyo suena
porque tiene pequeños estorbos
que esos estorbos
le dan sentido a la vida
porque los estorbos no son retos
nos han educado con retos
y en realidad no hay retos
lo que se nos presenta en la vida son
como esos pequeños peñascos que se
aparecen en los arroyos y que dan
chasquidos de plata
chasquidos de plata visos dorados
en una penumbra de humedad
acariciado por el shadows que tiende sus
ramas que acaricia el agua
y que después
se deja caer con enorme solemnidad en
las cascadas creando a veces sonidos de
estruendo
y a veces imágenes de melancolía y
grandeza
todo esto que es sensibilidad pura y que
está en la naturaleza propia de los
humanos y en la tarde naturaleza exc
externa que los artistas empiezan a
hacer síntesis detalle de toda esa
complejidad de las emociones y que esas
emociones son las que realmente mueven
al ser humano
son las emociones esto de la emotividad
el mundo del afecto
y que el afecto
cuando le exige le exige
la afectividad le exige a la razón que
se proyecte en una realidad concreta
esto es el paso de los ensueños de las
imaginaciones de las utopías de los
deseos todo eso es este compendio del
mundo onírico que se alimenta de las
realidades concretas de nuestros
paisajes humanos de nuestros paisajes
celestiales
y viene el acompañamiento de la cee
de la espiritualidad
esta espiritualidad que no es
claustro solo de las religiones
dogmáticas
yo conozco una muy buena cantidad de
ateos llenos de fe
porque la fe nos la exige la naturaleza
misma
la fe es este maravilloso contacto del
misterio con la creación concreta de lo
que estamos somos cada uno de nosotros
eso es el arte
el arte precipita
de manera concreta en la emoción de la
existencia precipita la grandeza de lo
divino en la grandeza de lo humano
no hay humano sin divinidad ni divinidad
sin la mano ese es el misterio de la
intuición artística como vincula los
misterios como se consagra toda la
grandeza
en un instante que es la unión de lo
eterno y este segundo que estamos
viviendo en este momento
en estas redes que aparecen y
desaparecen en la virtualidad visual en
los misterios de las neuronas que
trabajan en un silencio audible
el que sabe oír su propio silencio
está descubriendo la grandeza de su
propia creación
esa creación que le permite sentirse
necesario porque necesita al otro
que no existe solo
que se vincula a través del color oa
través del poema o de los sonidos de las
armas armonías de los ritmos en los que
la complejidad del ramaje de los súper
dinámicos a esta paz solemne del maestro
rosco por ejemplo
este rojo que sabe vincular
el mundo de las complejidades en la
simplicidad de un cuarto
y así podemos recorrer toda la historia
de la pintura
cuando entendemos estos aspectos
qué nos dicen todo
con unas cuantas manchas de color o la
complejidad del barroco y se me viene a
la maria a la cabeza
santa maría tonanzintla allá en puebla
en este barrio tan lleno tan lleno de
delicadezas ingenuas
esta palabra que se ha desaparecido en
el código de la complejidad de la
violencia
ingenuidad
la inocencia
términos que son despectivos cuando es
la verdadera grandeza del ser humano
en esta inocencia en esta ingenuidad
donde fecunda se toda la grandeza del
universo la grandeza se recuerda en esta
inocencia y en esta ingenuidad
los que conozcan santa maría tonanzintla
a lo mejor lo tienen más claro los que
no conozcan
son estos ángeles que parecen las monas
de cartón esas que venden en los en las
cuales más suya ni me acuerdo en las
pascuas y todo esto que extrañan esos
son simple y sencillamente la
simplicidad de la expresión de un
mestizo de un indígena o de un criollo
mezclado todo esto como mariposas que
quieren jugar en la libertad y algo las
atrapa y que cuando quedan atrapadas en
estos esqueletos mortuorios y que el
artista en este caso en este vídeo de
adrián verdad se juega en esta especie
de delicia que tiene la soledad y la
ingenuidad aún encarcelado en su propia
muerte
para la libertad no hay cárcel
la libertad desde el interior que
justamente juega con los atrapamientos
mortuorios pero que cuando entran en un
juego de síntesis espectacular en lo
visual en lo audible lo imaginario que
ya no le quedó más remedio a esta
calavera vomitar una especie de mariposa
pélvica
el arte está llena de metáforas el arte
es metáfora y cuando nos ponemos en un
plan más allá la vida es una metáfora de
lo divino
si nosotros entendemos lo que es y
sentimos la metáfora de lo divino pues
entonces nos divertimos con las obras de
arte
claro
bien en los silencios los silencios
interiores que no necesariamente son
reflexiones de que hicimos bien en que
hicimos mal
tengan amabilidad con nosotros mismos
la marca no es otra cosa sino que el
bien escondido en alguna parte de
nuestro interior
y si buscamos esa bondad
naturalmente va a fluir en el esplendor
de la belleza
los maravillosos amaneceres no
que tienen su parentesco con los
anocheceres como esas famosas de siete
de la tarde que cuando tuvimos una
parranda divertida no sabemos si está
amaneciendo o esta tarde ciento
quiero decirles que yo fui profesional
de esas faenas
entonces sé de lo que estoy hablando
entonces empieza el señor monet a
interpretar me
ahí está
estas estas impresiones / oscuridades y
grises y todo esto pero que también
entiende allí a poner
sol
en este caso fíjense como ese sol
derrama sus manchas en el esplendor de
los grises azulados no es otra cosa más
que la unión de los grandes misterios
celestiales puestos y embadurnados con
enorme elegancia en una charca en un mar
o en riachuelo que se llama la realidad
de nuestras vidas
hasta que va cobrando fuerza
pero
la esperanza cuando está puesta en el
escenario de la fe y la intuición del
artista también poco a poco va sufriendo
sus propias transfiguración es la
presencia del drama y la tragedia
cualquier drama en manos de shakespeare
de los griegos o de nuestros mismos
escritores nacionales tan expertos en la
tragedia no si la arquitectura
prehispánica es un poema de tragedia
maravilloso donde las danzas los
jubilosos y las recitaciones y los
cantos
se consumen se consumen y se consagran
en la cúspide de una pirámide para
ofrecer las vidas como un sol
para que después vuelva a salir
las tragedias
tienen un fondo maravillosamente poético
tienen esta necesidad de consagrarse el
ser humano con la propia naturaleza del
ser humano pero con la esperanza siempre
de renacer
el arte reclama más presencia a nuestros
días
son días aciagos
pero estamos puestos en el escenario de
la tragedia porque nos enteramos todos
los días de lo que pasa pero si ustedes
preguntan hace 200 años pregúntele al
señor goya lo que pinto
pintando tragedias en sus cartones
negros no hace 200 años o sea puede ser
para algunos de mi edad ayer
para nosotros puedes hacer hace muchos
años pero el mundo así es qué es lo que
hace el artista apaciguar los dolores no
darles una nueva perspectiva al mundo de
cómo lo concebimos como lo o cómo lo
traducimos ese es el gran misterio del
arte ese es el gran sentido de como el
artista logra el beso logra un beso
entre la autoría y la realidad concreta
eso es el artista es un verdadero mago
porque hace visible lo invisible
el mago
visible
y los poemas y las fábulas y los dramas
y las tragedias y los mitos los
maravillosos mitos que no quiere decir
otra cosa la palabra mito que quiere
decir palabra
y que esos pensamientos tan
completamente hermosos del mito
requiere
es un rapsoda
es este personaje que entiende el mito o
sea el misterio relacionado con la
realidad concreta quién sé qué maravilla
no eso es la maravilla del mito y el
rapsoda saben que hace
los cuenta
los canta
me encanta
porque porque el mito no resuelve
la chapa del mito no es resolver
es imaginar
meternos en los misterios
amar la duda
amar la duda pero como la duda la
tenemos puesta nada más en que si me
están poniendo los cuernos o no pues eso
esas dudas hombres son muy divertidas no
las dudas de la existencia las dudas de
la poesía
fíjense lo que va a pasar ahorita
va a empezar a parecer una nostalgia de
crueldad
la crueldad no tiene sentido en las
notas rojas
la crueldad tiene sentido cuando
entendemos al ser humano
su incapacidad
las razones que ustedes quieran
vista otra vez otra vez en su propia
ingenuidad en su propia inocencia para
percibir
hermosura de todo todo absolutamente
todo lo más
la crueldad el dolor la pasión
la felicidad la paz todo eso es lo
déjenme hallar una cosita que escribí
hace rato
que dije es buen punto para terminar
hay que meterle un lente aquí y hold
pero tiene que ser rapidísimo
fíjense ustedes
devorando nos unos a otros para que los
amaneceres de luz a los nuevos misterios
la fe y la autopisa la utopía se besen
en unión sagrado de lo humano el arte
alienta la rebeldía del desamparado y
también da paz al agraciado muchas
gracias